I ask you then do you think it was Boris
Johnson who made that decision to purge
his party of you guys who he himself out
it against for instance threes amazed
deal twice out of three times he went
with her once at the end but he didn't
lose the wit Theresa May didn't do that
to people that cabinet that you sat in
and on with Boris Johnson for some time
or do you think it's the work of an even
more unelected official Dominic Cummings
the mastermind of the levy you campaign
the official campaign who is it is it
Boris Johnson that's the puppet master
or is it is it Dominic doing this so I
think it's very important to understand
that in the end the buck stops with the
person in charge now it may be the case
that this is a strategy driven by
Dominic but the premise that appointed
Dominic the premises supports Dominic
and the premises signed off in the
strategy and the this is something that
often happens in regimes Annie Archie
used to happen traditionally with
medieval English kings the story was
always oh that the person at the top is
fine it's their advisers that's the
problem if only the King knew the
terrible things that their favorites and
advisers were doing and people actually
did this over with Nixon and Watergate
it was an enormous focus on their chiefs
of staff and the people under them and I
I think it's I think the sort of simple
view which is that you need to pin
responsibility on the elected person at
the top is the correct view and that
although it's tempting to imagine
there's some sort of secret Svengali who
does the whole thing you have to
acknowledge that the person at the top
has empowered that person given that
person apparent must bear moral
responsibility for what that person does
if the courts find Boris Johnson guilty
essentially of misleading her majesty
over the probation of Parliament next
week
he's Boris Johnson's position as prime
minister of this country untenable do
you think his position is untenable I
the risk though is that we get into a
form of trumpian politics in other words
almost certainly were the courts to find
against the prime minister he would like
Donald Trump just try to shrug it off
and say I don't care about the courts
I've got the people on my side and we
were getting a sense that already with
his approach prorogation his approach to
purging people his statements about the
fact that despite the fact that
Parliament has voted for an extension
he's not going to go to Brussels and
request that extension so what will
happen is not that his position becomes
untenable but that British politics will
become increasingly divisive and
polarized because he will have doubled
down on a tradition which I am also
responsible for so I understand this
cuts both ways that does
I'm obviously criticizing Boris for
being unconstitutional but remember I
also participate in a vote
I voted against No Deal brexit and that
vote was made possible by the speaker
breaking constitutional convention by
allowing asked to introduce a positive
motion on a particular type of special
order of the house so that there is a
bigger problem happening in British
politics which is when it suits us far
too many of us are trying to break the
rules to suit our own position let me be
provocative to a crowd that is is
overwhelmingly a remain crowd you how
did you know about do they smell a
certain way please please put up your
hand if you voted remain
it was a good guess okay so it's always
good to check a lot of presumption in
politics isn't always good absolutely we
have to we have to have some intuitions
as politicians so we can't really
operate at all but the I mean with you
know if you look at people's attitude
towards the second referendum you can
feel the same thing which is that for
many of us we are beginning to get into
a mindset that the end justifies the
means that we are becoming increasingly
determined to ignore process and
outcomes we don't like in order to get
to what we think is right and so I think
if we're going to challenge what Boris
is doing which is what I want to do we
also have to be quite disciplined with
ourselves and people like me need to be
more careful about how I approach the
constitutional process as well as
attacking him on the other direction I
think it's a very interesting point to
make but I've particularly asked that
question about Boris Johnson's position
becoming untenable not just because it
came up on social media it was one of
the questions that came in but but also
because people like Sabine Campbell
former leader of the Lib Dems
a Scottish QC a former Scottish QC has
actually said he has to resign next week
because you can't lie to the Queen about
your real reasons for suspending
Parliament not least when your Defence
Secretary has been overheard saying at
an event well the real reason we did it
was because we need some space and a
lack of scrutiny on brexit I'm badly
paraphrasing Ben Wallace but that he's
out there in the public domain if
nothing else so I just wanted to
understand why do you think somebody
like that who no longer really does have
skin in the political game would say
that and he wasn't saying it in a
mischievous way he's saying in a very
serious so I think I'm at that in the
past Prime Minister's almost certainly
would have resigned so but but we're
getting into the this is why I'm drawing
the analogy with Trump yes I mean if you
basically if you were the editor of the
New York Times you would have felt for
the last two-and-a-half years you had
produced the story every week that would
inevitably lead to the resignation of
the president and doesn't so Ming is
correct I think
in the past many of these things would
lead to resignation but I also think
that my reading of the strategy that
Boris is pursuing is such that he's very
very unlikely to respond to a court case
by resigning because he probably feels
that a chunk of the country I don't know
how much chunk of the country but a
chunk of the country will support him
because the chunk of the country will
feel here is this out-of-touch group of
people sitting on the top of a pyramid I
know who they are they're politicians
that journalists they're judges and
they're trying to undermine the will of
the people and if he aligns himself with
people against them and portrays the
judges as being part of this
out-of-touch conspiracy he can he can
ride it through Parliament versus the
people establishment versus the people's
trust and and and he is a sort of I
think for many of his voters he's a sort
of hand grenade which is being thrown at
that group for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at III TV
you